l'amour
ce soir
le vent qui frappe à ma porte
nous parle des amours mortes
devant le feu qui s'étend
ce soir
c'est une chance en ôta
dans la maison qui ferait ça
et je pense
aux gens lointain
que reste-t-il
de nos amours
le rester
seconde
une faute
une photo de ma jeunesse
que reste-t-il
du pays d'où
des mois d'après
rendez vous
souvenez
mais pour sûr
sans cesse
onair fanni
cheveux sombres
des ces bonus
aurez vous
tu
tout cela
pour moi
un petit village
vieux clocher
un paysage
c'est bien caché
dans un nuage
cher l'isard
de mon passé
les mots les mots tendres qu'on murmure
les caresses les plus pures les serments
font les mots et
les fleurs que l'on retrouve dans un
livre dont le parfum aux années
se sont envolés
pourquoi
que reste-t-il
de nos amours
que reste t-il
c'est pour vous non
une photo
il ya une poste
ma jeunesse
que reste des
billets doux et mois d'avril les rangs
des
insomnies
le procès
sans cesse
bonheur année
je deux ans
mais c'est paris ouais
st
vite le besoin
une petite ville à
un vieux cacher
un paysage
si bien caché
et dans un nuage
de chair et visage
de mon
c